oui c'est peut-être pas le début on
pourrait dire puisque c'est en 2019 que
l'Église
orthodoxe d'Ukraine a été créé avec
l'autocéphalie qu'il y a été accordé par
le patriarque de Constantinople mais
depuis seulement environ 1500 des
églises qui dépendaient du Patriarcat de
Moscou en Ukraine se sont ralliés à la
nouvelle église
ukrainienne ce qui laisse plus de 10000
dépendants du Patriarcat de Moscou dont
la monastère des caves à keV l'un des
établissements religieux les plus
importants du monde
orthodoxe qui est derrière moi et eu des
enquêteurs
Ukrainiens où on perquisitionné les
lieux il y a une dizaine de jours et des
raides sur toute une gamme de église
dépendante de l'église de Moscou ont eu
lieu ces derniers jours y compris ce
matin ils ont découvert à l'intérieur de
ces églises certaines d'entre eux en
tout cas des matériels de propagande
russe et c'est cela qui a porté cette
décision de volody Muriel ski et du
Conseil national de défense ukrainienne
pour qui il est clair que même si le
Patriarcat de Moscou on Ukraine dit
avoir coupé les liens avec Moscou et
être clairement du côté de l'Ukraine
l'évidence qui a été trouvée dans ces
établissements semblerait indiquer que
ce n'est pas vraiment le cas et que ces
églises peuvent être encore des agents
d'influence russe dans ce pays Akerson
la ville est toujours bombardée par les
Russes malgré le retour de l'électricité
les habitants
Ukrainiens continuent de prendre la
fuite
oui l'électricité va et vient en fait à
cause des bombardements à Herson qui
arrive à le couper et puis c'est rétabli
je ne sais pas exactement quelle est la
situation à l'heure où je vous parle
mais certainement les attaques sur
personne semblent destinées à continuer
de la même de serguer la prof le
ministre russe des Affaires étrangères
qui a comparé la ville de Herson à
Stalingrad qui a été bombardé par la
Russie pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale pendant qu'elle était occupée
par l'Allemagne nazie pour servir la
prof personne est maintenant une ville
russe après l'annexion annoncée le 30
septembre malgré le fait que des facto
étaient jurés aussi bien sûr aux yeux de
la loi ukrainienne et internationale
elle dépend absolument de l'Ukraine et
ce sont les forces ukrainiennes qui ont
repris le contrôle il y a deux semaines
de la ville de Herson les Ukrainiens
qualifient ces attaques de revanche les
rustices qu'ils vont continuer à
bombarder la ville pour de ton chasser
les Ukrainiens merci beaucoup Gulliver
CRA